En tu cuestionario de mate ganas 5 puntos
por cada pregunta que respondes correctamente.
En la tabla de abajo, "x" representa el número
de preguntas que contestas correctamente en
tu cuestionario y "y" representa el número
total de puntos que obtienes en tu cuestionario.
La relación entre estas dos variables puede
ser expresada por la siguiente ecuación,
"y" igual a "5x"
Grafica la ecuación abajo.
Para esto podemos tomar un par de puntos,
si tenemos 0 respuestas correctas, tenemos 0 puntos.
Graficamos entonces ese punto.
Tengo 0 respuestas correctas, tengo 0 puntos.
Y si tengo una respuesta correcta, nos lo
da la tabla o podemos pensar que cada respuesta
correcta nos da 5 puntos, así es que por
una respuesta correcta tenemos 5 puntos.
Así es que si tengo una respuesta correcta,
voy a tener 5 puntos,
esto lo vemos también en la tabla,
una respuesta correcta 5 puntos.
También podemos graficar dos
respuestas correctas, 10 puntos.
Cualquiera de estos puntos sirve, solo se
necesitan dos puntos para definir una recta.
Así es que parece que aquí ya hemos terminado.